we're joined by one of our closest
friends a sister if you will a sister
show a sister you can catch her at the
helm of entertainment tonight every
night of the week please welcome back to
the show my sister and your friend
michelle turner
i am
i am overjoyed to be here so let's first
talk about the new hot couple that
everybody's talking about and you know
who that is you all know right we all
know i mean can we say it together yeah
kim kardashian and pete davidson
which i love how you put it ross i love
that you call it the relationship we
didn't know we needed i had no idea and
then as soon as they were like dating i
was like oh
i like it
i do like i'm intrigued by it i'm not
sure what i think about it yet because
you know they said of course the line
that you always get tell me what you
know
well they they at first said we're just
friends totally right we're just friends
y'all knew that wouldn't that y'all knew
when they you saw their hands
interlocked at not scary farms you knew
there was a lot not how i held hands but
not with my we've been holding hands and
we've been going like this i know ross
and i always say there's a big
difference between that and that there
you go that's second base in
well now hand-holding then when he
brought her to staten island i was like
you got kim k to staten island
honey something's going on and she put
on a fashion show walking dinner so yeah
so first they said they were just
friends but we now know they are more
than friends now it is interesting
because kim says um she wants to we have
a source that says she wants to protect
kanye's feelings and all of this so she
does want to tread lightly but i have to
say she has been on display for the
cameras walking to dinner so
i don't i don't know we know we also
know kanye's kind of dating himself oh
really yeah but who's he dating who is
she's a model and she's gorgeous
okay he's good
a minute here because then i heard him
speaking on a podcast about no we're
still married
he hasn't seen any paperwork she's not
my ex-wife she's still my wife we have
not signed any paperwork and he did say
my kids want us to be together and i
want us to be together so
it changes every day with them we do
know right now kim and pete are casually
dating kanye seems to be dating someone
else i just wonder what chris jenner
thinks of it all she's thinking we got a
hulu show coming baby because that's
what she's thinking she's thinking she's
thinking
of course
they just started shooting their hulu
show and what do they have so far
uh chloe and true get covered courtney
gets engaged and kim gets a new dude i
know i mean come on i know just wait
till next
week exactly
who is happy yes they are all right next
up we have to talk about megan the
stallion come on true love i love her so
much i know you do i love you so much
thank you so amazing
she's incredible what an artist and now
she's about to complete her college
degree come on meg that deserves a hand
class
because there's like nothing she can't
do right
right it really isn't yeah no next month
the body yada yada rapper gets her
bachelor at a bachelor degree oh from
texas southern university did i pull
that off and um you guys are reporting
that her graduation photo shoot uh
stayed two to her hot girl form yes well
she did have the cap and gown but of
course meg gave us uh you know what is
it a hot girl summer and uh you know
what girl fall
she had a bikini on
the cabin gown she is amazing everything
she does every single thing she does
turns to gold do we know what's next for
her because i mean is that new music
coming out well uh
this weekend she is expected to perform
at the amas the american music awards
with bts how about that oh my god
[Applause]
um well speaking of purple um house of
gucci had its premiere and all eyes were
on that glam red carpet and lady gaga
didn't let everybody down
in head to toe gucci
[Applause]
underneath she may be getting another
oscar the reviews are so good for her
performances
her and jared leto yeah that's a clap
her and jared leto are getting so much
buzz for this um the reviews are great
for them like you said this is her
secondly only her second leading role i
love lady gaga so much she is our modern
david bowie absolutely she is that's
really a great assessment that's an
amazing there's nothing that's stephanie
germanotti
bring it on
[Applause]
every week night
[Music]